and joining me now is the European
policy officer for profi a German farm
animal welfare organization Sabina all
thank you for being with us on the shoe
you grew up with pharmacy yourself so
obviously you do have the perspective
farmers complain a lot though people say
even though they receive a lot of
subsidies here in Europe so what is
really wrong well the whole policy has
gone wrong a long time ago and farmers
are right to complain because it can
continue this way we actually tried to
support them in finding ways of changing
the system and changing the whole
subsidies and the farm animal keeping
around changing the system is really
hard if you look at the way it works
some people take food as a commodity
that they speculate on that they bet on
that keeps prices going up or going down
so the whole market is really volatile
how do you change this spiral well we
did have a chance actually in 2013 the
farm animal the cap reform for the
Common Agricultural Policy of the
European Union was decided upon and we
could have done better obviously there
was a bad compromise that was found in
the end and we're going to try to make
it better in 2020 when there's the next
chance of really profoundly reforming
there will be a midterm review in the
middle and there will be steps to be
taken what's the biggest challenge there
what do you have to change in 2020 that
you didn't manage to change now well in
Europe we have to really work for
towards a more sustainable agricultural
policy and we cannot continue to just
pay subsidies to farmers on the basis of
owning hectares of arable land we need
to really pay for a public good it's
animal welfare but also obviously
environmental protection and the climate
change protection against climate change
which play a big role biodiversity /
protection right also but there's
something else that is playing a big
role supply and demand and if I look at
other sectors this basics
space is basically economy seems to work
very well in other sectors but not in
the agricultural sector of Europe what's
the problem well there's different
reasons for that food is not a commodity
like any other commodity because of
course now we've had a long period of
peace in Europe but that hasn't always
been the case and there's no guarantee
for it to stay that way although we all
hope for it so every country wants to
produce most of the food that is
consumed they're basically himself
because that's uh give them more
security food security in their own
country also it's perishable and of
course if we talk about cows you know
you cannot just switch on a button and
switch it back off when you may need
more milk or less so you have to provide
for a longer period we'll talk about
this in just a minute from savino